a bipartisan group of lawmakers is
backing an effort to close what it sees
is a loophole that supports online
market for sex trafficking 47 senators
almost half of the Senate are
co-sponsoring a bill they want to remove
legal protections for websites that host
prostitution ads but some in law
enforcement
warn the effort could be
counterproductive Anna Warner shows us
how the bill is aimed primarily at one
site backpage.com it's called and a good
morning good morning the National Center
for Missing and Exploited Children says
Backpage is involved in nearly
three-quarters of all reports of online
child sex trafficking that it receives
from the general public a Senate
investigation showed adult ads proved to
be big business for Backpage generating
more than ninety percent of its ad
revenue in 2011 some victims advocates
want the site shut down but is it that
simple the man leaving this Chicago area
hotel room thought he'd be meeting a
prostitute instead he and other men
found undercover police officers waiting
we've blurred their faces they'd
responded to ads police had posted on
the classifieds website back page
commander bill lean heads the Vice unit
when you put an ad like this up how long
does it take before you get responses Oh
usually within a minute or two calls yes
really and how many calls we get
sometimes we'll get 50-100 and a night
now that's despite the fact that back
page shut down its adult advertising
section earlier this year under pressure
from lawmakers now police say they find
ads for sex with young girls in the web
sites dating section we've made over
1,000 arrests off a back page a thousand
Tom dart is Cook County Sheriff and were
you shocked when you first saw what was
happening online
I honestly even being a former
prosecutor I couldn't believe what I was
seeing
dart says many of the girls advertised
are victims of sex trafficking this
teenager says she was one of them I was
naive the 17 year old and her mother
asked us not to show their face
but the teen says a pimp seduced her
when she was just 14 years old and
convinced her to post on Backpage
there's like hundreds of guys responding
to the hundreds of guys mm-hmm
she says the pimp told her to book
appointments with men then send him the
money on a good day I would make like a
thousand and how many guys on average
would that be for a good day like four
it's kind of like you were working as a
sex slave yeah
he even branded her with a tattoo he
later pled guilty to human trafficking
and is serving eight years in prison and
she's now filed a lawsuit accusing
Backpage of negligence among other
allegations what do you think back page
coms role in all of this is our
responsibility is there letting all this
happen on their website I mean without
back page I would have never been in any
of this in the first place the girl's
mother back page has a primary purpose
and it's to sell sex back page has not
done anything to ensure the safety of
the kids on their period the company
recently settled a similar lawsuit in
Washington but it's also won several
legal decisions in part because of a
federal law called the Communications
Decency Act the company has argued in
court filings that under the Act
websites cannot be held liable for
publishing or editing content provided
by third party users but a Senate report
alleges Backpage knowingly concealed
evidence of child sex trafficking
through its editing by deleting words
phrases and images indicative of
criminality Senate investigators said
words like young little girl and
innocent were removed while the
remainder of the ad would be published
raise your right hand at a congressional
hearing in January Backpage executives
took the fifth
to answer your question the company also
declined an on-camera interview but a
representative told US senators are
conducting a witch-hunt against the site
Backpage says it cooperates with police
departments to help find victims and
some police like minneapolis sergeant
grant snyder a sex trafficking
investigator agree in some cases we just
tell them we've got a victim out there
and we need to recover this individual
and and they respond very rapidly to
that Schneider also agrees with Backpage
that if ads aren't on their site they'll
pop up somewhere else on sites that may
not be as helpful to police I think that
if we eliminated Backpage today you
would see the same level of commercial
exploitation occurring in other venues
but sheriff dart doesn't buy the
argument I would hope our bar would be a
lot higher than that that your entire
logic behind it is like well it could be
just really really worse so just allow
this to continue to go on sheriff dart
pressured credit card companies to stop
doing business with the site Backpage is
now suing him for that saying it
violated the First Amendment and the
Communications Decency Act a Senate
committee last week approved legislation
that would revise the Communications
Decency law to specify that it doesn't
provide protection for sex trafficking
the bill now heads to the full Senate
for consideration a sex trafficking a
big problem the bigger problem that many
people realize in this country yes
important since they don't likely to
pass well the internet groups drop their
opposition which i think was a big
hurdle after they made some changes in
the bill so that would seem to increase
the likelihood that it would pass nice
to see it's important bipartisanship
though in Washington on some issues
mm-hmm thank you Anna
today on our CBS this morning podcast
you can hear the story behind the back
page investigation learn why Anna and
her producers started looking into back
page in the first place and how this
story developed you can hear our podcast
on itunes and apple's podcast app